they don't realize that it cuts against
their alarmist arguments they don't
realize
how incoherent the lockdown measures
appear but people are getting fed up
with it and it's not just
conservatives and talking heads and
republican politicians
it's not it's regular old people people
who own businesses
people who are in very blue places
california la la land especially
under mayor garcetti's control has
locked down again
this was after restaurants shut down
then they reopened and they were told
they had to go outside they invest lots
and lots of money friend of mine
who works for a restaurant in la said
they they invested a hundred thousand
dollars turning their parking lot into
an outdoor area to eat
that was just shut down again too so
they're locking all that down meanwhile
though
the pet projects of these politicians
are allowed to continue undeterred there
was a woman in los angeles
who stands to lose everything she's a
restaurant owner who points out
that the politicians shut down her
business
but they permitted almost an identical
type of business to operate
right next door so this is my place the
pineapple hill grill in saloon
if you go to my page you can see all the
work i did for outdoor dining
for tables being seven feet apart and i
come in today
because i'm organizing a protest and i
came in to get
stuff for that and i walk
into my parking lot and obviously mayor
garcetti has approved
this
has approved
being set up for this being set up
for for a movie company
so if if you can
see this this is an open area giant
tents big tables because la is a show
business town so they want to be able to
make movies and when you make movies you
need these areas for people to eat
and hang out so they set up functionally
an outdoor
restaurant right next to
an outdoor restaurant they say no the
outdoor restaurant has to shut down but
the movie theater the
the the movie production set
may remain open why well i don't know
because the restaurants spread
coronavirus but the movies do not
you might say oh those incompetent
politicians oh they just don't think
about it oh how silly how ridiculous
it's not just silly it's not just
something to laugh at
many many people are going to lose
everything
they're going to lose their life savings
they're going to lose their business
many many many people are going to be
put out of work because these capricious
politicians
can't let go of power they can't let go
of their
ability to arbitrarily decide what
succeeds and what fails and
what people are allowed to do which
changes every hour of the day and this
woman is rightly
furious i'm losing everything
everything i own is being taken away
from me and they set up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio which is
right over here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive
my staff cannot survive look at this
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me as a slap in my
face that's safe
this is safe 50 feet away
is dangerous mayor garcetti and gavin
newsom is responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
absolutely right this is maybe the most
ridiculous example of this you've seen
but you've seen
other examples of this from the
beginning here you have
actually two of identical operations
one is now illegal one of them is legal
and actually if it's movies it's
probably being subsidized in part by the
government
that's ridiculous but you've seen it
from the beginning you're allowed to go
out and
riot for blm but you're not allowed to
go to church why because
blm and woke-ism and political
correctness is the
established religion of the the liberal
state and
christianity and judaism or are
repressed and suppressed religion so
you're allowed to go to the good
religion you're not allowed to go
to the politically incorrect religion
gorsetti has a pretty weak response to
all of this
gorcetti says to the new york times in
response to this viral video
my heart goes out to ms morriston and
the workers at the pineapple hill saloon
who have to comply with state and county
public health restrictions that close
outdoor dining
no one likes these restrictions but i do
support them as our hospital icu beds
fill the capacity
and cases have increased by 500 we must
stop this virus before it kills
thousands of more angelenos
that's not an answer buddy because
her problem isn't even that you've shut
down the outdoor dining
it's that you've only shut down some
outdoor dining you've shut down her
outdoor dining but then you've permitted
other outdoor dining to crop up directly
next to her
no no one is saying that if the policies
were coherent
then we would have them what we're
saying is these policies are completely
incoherent
one day we're told you can't wear the
masks the next day we're told you have
to wear the masks
one day we're told you can't go outside
you certainly can't protest
against the lockdown restrictions the
next day we're told you need to go
gather on mass by the thousands
to go protest for blm
or protest with antifa we're told by
these
these scoundrels like eric garcetti that
we all have to make sacrifices we all
look we all have to these politicians do
not believe in this
they don't abide by their own mandates
and they don't fear the virus
if they feared the virus then gavin
newsom wouldn't go to the french laundry
and yuck it up with all his buddies
shoulder to shoulder no masks
indoors and then come out and pretend oh
gosh
what a lapse of judgment oh what an
accident nancy pelosi wouldn't show up
masculist to her hair salon
chris cuomo wouldn't pretend to be
quarantining with the virus
actually go bike riding in the hamptons
get into a fight with one of his
neighbors because one of his neighbors
made fun of him called him out for lying
on television then lie about it on tv
again
all of these people thought you wouldn't
be caught with his mask down time and
time again
these guys do not believe it they do not
fear the virus
in the alarmist way that they are trying
to get you to fear the virus
[Music]
[Music]